alors honnêtement je pense pas qu'elle
ait décidé de révéler ça maintenant
maintenant ça nous tombe dessus oui mais
il paraît alors on a quelques infos il
semblerait qu'ils soient allés au
restaurant ensemble bref sens et voilà
c'est assez connu il faut il s'en
sortait du restaurant quand on veut pas
que ça ça je croyais moi prise de
risques ça manger des plats la maison
s'est classé 9e à berne à monthois je
suis bien placé pour le savoir que
croyez moi quand on exerce apparemment
le nouveau compagnon donc j'allais
l'espère on vient de le dire il l'aurait
souhaité faire un biopic de johnny
hallyday donc c'est comme ça qui le
rapprochait laetitia donc souhaitant
rendre hommage à son homme celui qu'elle
a personal depuis des mois des mois des
mois donc à son mari barack tu vois là
oui bien sûr et donc le premier contact
aurait été appelé comme ça il se serait
jouée à paris il ya quelques jours
apparemment ce sera un gros coup de
foudre battre m écouter alors moi je
veux dire honnêtement aux idées des
heureux elle a un nouvel homme dans sa
vie
là franchement oui à moi je serai pas de
ceux qui vous rue avec les loups c'est
qu'après faut pas tout mélanger
tiens pourquoi pas c'est un choix et que
maintenant le plus jeune plus tellement
comme l'aveu parce que les pêcheurs ne
veut même pas une nouvelle vie bah oui
d'arrêter de ménageries sait nager la
chèvre et les chewing gums
c'est moi ou non les bras m'en tombent
[Musique]
chaque semaine superbe
excusez moi oui pour ça c'est un
scandale je ne l'aiment pas cet l'été ça
c'est un scandale elle fait tout pour se
faire remarquer alors il faut être serré
parce que c'est quand même tu sais quand
même c'est quand même important et c'est
un scandale
on parle de l'amour mais pour de vrai
exploit est finalement celui qui est pas
manipuler et qui passe un peu point un
bouffon enfin c'est l'ex une bonne heure
demain c'est parce que maintenant car
s'il a fait un peu de temps pour
atterrir en plus a dit qu'elle l'a
quittée parce que l'ombre de johnny
planait autour d'eux et donc tu as tu te
remets avec quelqu'un d'autre est comme
ça l'ombre ne va plus planer oui mais
alors elle avait là la différence juste
à défendre c'est qu'elle est avec un
personnage public et connu donc ça peut
aussi atténué l'ombre de johnny qu'en
pensez vous non je suis pas je suis
plutôt perplexe à leurs abonnés pourquoi
pas si complexe parce que effectivement
comme vous le disiez instant je trouve
que les choses sont trop bien avant ce
voyage nous le dira y'a pas coïncidence
dans dans la vie qui soit aussi énorme
et tout qui arrivent et le pauvre ex
comment il s'appelle déjà le pascal car
sa note
le pauvre pascal bats j'espère que comme
en compte qu'en tout cas il aura passé
un bon moment mais sur balles à damas
totalement et à utiliser c'est un peu le
dindon de la farce quoi moi oui alors
oui ce que c'est et sionistes en amour
est ce que je sais pas ce que je il se
trouve que je connais une des meilleures
amies de pascal ballon il n'a jamais été
à l'aise avec cette célébrité il a en
plus c'était quand même le compagnon
d'une femme détester leçon le prouve
encore ce soir je ne sais pas pourquoi
on la déteste à ce moment là mais on la
déteste
attention c'est pourquoi on sait
pourquoi on aime on essaie à je vais
vous dire pourquoi je sais c'est qu'à
l'origine du décès du déshérités
david et de leur race et une loi pour ça
de la haine à ce point là on peut lui
reprocher des choses moi aussi je trouve
qu'il ya des shows mais bon je trouve
que voilà c'est une peine
disproportionnée et en fait vraiment il
n'a pas été à l'aise évidemment avec
cette ombre de johnny mais aussi ça
vraiment je le sais de source sûre avec
cette notoriété présente et là je pense
que vous l'avez un petit peu dit tout à
l'heure le fait qu'elle soit avec
quelqu'un de connu
il a été lui-même avec sonia rolland
c'est à dire une miss est une miss
france
il a déjà il a le mode d'emploi en fait
je pense et ce jeu je crois plus dans la
faculté qui est un mode d'emploi pour
l'amérique celle menée dans trois mois
je cherche depuis des années mais
dynamique ceci dit je vous le dis par
expérience je vois personne connue
ensemble c'est con mais c'est compliqué
donc dans ce cas précis ça peut être un
avantage et comédienne sonia rolland l'a
dit justement chez lui dans les colonnes
de paris match elle a réellement
ensemble avec jalil lespert et a dit
qu'elle l'a quitté et rookies ont un
enfant d'ailleurs une fille qui
s'appelle kahina ils sont restés neuf
heures ensemble et a dit qu'elle l'a
quitté au bout d'un moment parce qu'elle
ne se sentait pas soutenu
professionnellement et personnellement a
effectivement il peut y avoir problème
célébrités puis célébrité c'est parce
que m'avait dit ça évidemment nous
concernant des liens autre chemin- mais
alors est ce que vous pensez qu'il sera
pour le coup soutenir l'été ça parce que
je pense que diane il en termes de
d'abord de notoriété et lahoud est moins
connu que laëtitia mais il a une
carrière incroyable de cinéma de lettres
et terra un très bon comédien très bon
réalisateur donc est ce que vous pensez
qu'il sera utile à l'été cyril sont en
tout cas ils ne sont pas du tout en
concurrence parce que sonia rolland
était actrice il était quand même dans
ce milieu elle laëtitia est très célèbre
mais elle n'a pas professionnellement en
tout cas elle ne prétend pas à être
actrice à être santos donc je pense
qu'il peut l'épauler pour autre chose
mais qu'avait déjà il marque beaucoup de
points au départ il a quand même voulu
faire un biopic sur johnny donc rendre
hommage à johnny hallyday ce que veut
faire laëtitia depuis des mois des mois
donc face on va forcément se diriger
vers un nouveau business entre
guillemets poissarde géniale idée alors
qu'est ce que je sais dit à deux pics vu
par laëtitia ne se serait pas le bon
choix
là j'ai tout de suite ça va être
heureuse il faut apparemment c'est à peu
près quoi c'est tous les trois mois à
peu près cahier à nouveau je vous trouve
dur autant gt gt qui pour trouver que
c'était très dur pour laura et pour
david autant je trouve que en vouloir à
une femme qui refait sa vie fait que ça
totalement injuste la nouvelle droite
c'est une touche d'humour même si on ne
peut plus rigoler rester dans mon rôle
je repars dans le public
il n'empêche que sous couvert de
rigolade je suis d'accord avec jean
pascal à des gens pas que je suis
d'accord avec eux et attend des moutons
ne prononce pas ces gens là sont ils
amoureux oui ou non elles ont dit que la
maman était très ennuyée par cette
célébrité mais il l'aimé où il l'aimé
pas on s'en fout des problèmes
d'autorité si on aime la femme avec
laquelle on est si jal il est est
vraiment amoureux d'eux ils vont faire
leur truc peut-être le biopic et
l'essentiel de leur vie vont la vivre
ensemble et les autres mais son volume
des gens amoureux alors nous revenons
alors qu'ici déjà senti qu'une star
personnes saluaient qui vaut bonjour
j'ai basque a abandonné pour nom
générique avec moi
elle me l'ont là et c'est un très bon
souvenir d'accord mais à l'époque on a
dû se séparer parce que comme inquiété
quand même deux personnes connues ça a
été très compliqué à vivre séparées à
excuser est-ce que c'était compliqué ça
m'intéresse est-ce que c'est compliqué
on est de sauter pendant la tournée à
prester pas ce n'était pas un amour
peut-être comme ne sais pas mais c'était
trop au début il était amoureux à moi je
l'aimé beaucoup des personnes très bon
souvenir